In the last couple of weeks, you probably
heard me use the term management by optics,
and I've used this term to refer to the handling
of coronavirus by Donald Trump in the administration,
and I've also applied it to Mike Pence and
Donald Trump's non use of masks during recent
public appearances.
And there's now a new report from the Associated
Press.
Excellent article, which says that indeed,
according to people close to Trump, not authorized
to speak about this.
Trump is refusing to wear a mask in public
because no one he believes he would look ridiculous
wearing one and number two.
And this is the more interesting piece.
He believes it'll hurt his chances at being
reelected because of the message that wearing
a mask would send.
And we'll get to that report in a second.
So one example of management by optics is
the case.
Numbers in the death numbers are a disaster.
We've been in these sort of rolling patchworks
of stay at home orders now for close to two
months.
And the numbers are terrible.
Every day we're finding around 25000 new cases
of coronavirus despite testing not having
increased that dramatically or much at all
over the last half month or so.
We had it spikes once again this week to twenty
five hundred deaths on multiple days during
the week.
So the way that Trump is managing by optics
is simply not talking about deaths and cases.
Manage the optics, which are say that we won.
Talk about these heroic warriors, which are
the Americans Trump is talking about.
Talk about how we are now getting to reopen
the economy in 30 states or whatever the number
they claim is are starting to reopen their
state economies.
Mike Pence didn't wear a mask when he went
to the Mayo Clinic recently and he was excoriated
for it, ended up wearing a mask on his next
visit out.
But again, it's the optics of if you say things
are going really well, if you say we're past
the peak.
If you say we've won, if you say we are now
in the recovery mode, you certainly can't
be seen wearing a mask for the first time
in public.
That would imply things are not as good as
you claim they are.
So that gets us to Donald Trump earlier this
week.
Donald Trump flew out to Arizona.
We covered it, covered some of his live events
there.
He went literally to a mask factory, a factory
repurposed facility of Honeywell, where they
are making masks and they have in, you know,
right on the wall on a TV.
It is mandatory masks keep a mask on at all
times.
Trump didn't wear a mask.
And one is once again, we knew we suspected,
based on what we know about Trump, that this
is more management by optics.
Trump wearing a mask when he says, we've basically
won.
We're past it.
We're reopening.
It's all great.
He succeeded at keeping the death toll well
below 2 million.
It doesn't send the right signal.
And indeed, that's exactly what the new report
says.
Trump believes that if he was seen wearing
a mask, it would hurt his chances of reelection.
It would make him look ridiculous.
Trump has had two advisers that wearing a
mask would, quote, send the wrong message
and it would make him seem preoccupied with
health.
I for me, it would be good.
I would love to see Trump preoccupied with
health.
That's the problem.
The problem is he seems not to care about
health.
Trump also has told confidants, according
to the same Associated Press report, that
he fears he would look ridiculous in a mask
and that the image of him wearing a mask would
be used in negative ads against him.
Understand the insanity of that.
The mask has become a proxy political statement
at this point in time.
If you wear a mask, it means you believe this
is serious.
You believe things are bad.
You believe people should be scared.
Not wearing a mask means you don't trust these
hoaxer governors or everything's fine, or
the economy will soon be open and people will
soon or have already stopped dying from Corona
virus.
It's now a political statement, something
that is just supposed to be a matter of science.
Just to be supposed be a matter of health.
The masks are worn for very empirical, demonstrable
reasons.
Now they have become political calculations,
and I hate to tell you.
Maybe Trump is making the right calculation
for his followers.
Seeing Trump wear a mask to somebody like
me would say Trump understands the science.
Trump trusts the experts.
Trump cares about other people.
But Trump is the guy who looked directly at
a solar eclipse and he's making the equivalent
choice here with the masks.
Now, I have to tell you the looking ridiculous
thing.
This is not a show that focuses on things
like the physical appearance of our elected
officials, but Trump saying the mask will
make me look ridiculous.
Trump has been going around with a lunatic
looking fake tan for years.
He walks around in these oversized suits very
often.
Even if we grant the concern about looking
ridiculous with the mask and how that might
affect his supporters or whatever, Trump regularly
looks ridiculous.
And so that is also sort of a complicated
thing to get a sense of.
But it's not the most important thing.
The most important thing here is the continued
management by optics and the really sad reality
that when it comes to his followers, he may
be right.
His followers may see him wearing a mask and
actually be turned off by it.
And unfortunately, when Trump's followers
see him not wearing a mask, it encourages
them not to wear one, which leads to viral
spread, which leads to cases which leads to
deaths.
It's very, very ugly.
Management by optics, extraordinarily dangerous.
And we're seeing that in action.
Look at the case numbers in these states.
Look at what's happening in Texas.
Look at what's happening in Georgia.
Arizona states that are reopening early.
It's not good and it's getting worse.
And now Donald Trump is proactively set.
Now, I'm not going to be seen with a mask
that'll be used
in ads.